if i may make a
comment an aside about henry kissinger
so he i think at 98 years old currently
has still got it
yeah he's brilliant
it's very very impressive i
can only hope that my brain has the same
durability that his his does because
it's a formidable intellect and it's
still in
in as sharp form as it it was 50 years
ago so you mentioned eric schmitz and
his book
they reached out to me didn't want to do
this podcast
and i'm i'm i know eric schmidt i've
spoken before i like him a lot obviously
um
so they said
we could do a podcast for 40 minutes
with eric
40 minutes with eric and henry together
and 40 minutes with henry so those are
three different conversations
and i had to like i had to do some soul
searching because i said fine 40 minutes
with eric we'll probably talk many times
again
fine let's talk about this ai book
together for 40 minutes
but i said uh what i wrote to them said
i would hate myself if i only have 40
minutes to talk to henry kissinger
as i had to hold my ground went back and
forth in the end decided to part ways
over this and i sometimes think about
this kind of
difficult decision
in the podcasting space
of
when do you walk away
because um
there's a particular world leader
that i've mentioned in the past where
the conversation is very likely to
happen
and
as as it happens
those conversations can often be
you know unfortunately this person only
has 30 minutes now i know we agreed for
three hours but unfortunately and you
have to decide do i stand my ground on
this
on this point i suppose that's the thing
that journalists
have to think about right like um
do i hold on to my integrity in whatever
form that takes and do i stain my ground
even if i
lose a fascinating opportunity anyway
something i thought i thought about and
something i think about and with henry
kissinger i mean
he's had a million amazing conversations
in your biography so it's not like
something is lost but it was still
nevertheless to me some soul searching
they had to do as a as a kind of
practice for
to what to me is a higher stakes
conversation
i'll just mention is vladimir putin um
i can have a conversation with him
unlike any conversation he's ever had
partially because i'm a fluent russian
speaker
partially because i'm messed up in the
head in certain kind of ways that make
for an interesting dynamic because we're
both judo people we both are
certain kinds of human beings that can
have a much deeper apolitical
conversation
you